I don't want sort of a naively
optimistic view of human nature that
they're simply people are simply good I
think there's a lot of potential for
both very good and very bad things in in
people you know the word you know ape
already in Shakespeare in English
simultaneously meant primate and to
imitate and I think there's something
about human nature that's very heavily
driven by by by by sort of imitation by
looking at what other people are doing
and it's very heavily shaped by what's
considered acceptable or not and so you
know you know if your parents encouraged
you to become a suicide bomber there's a
chance you'll become a suicide bomber
and you know something like this trip an
awful lot of awful lot of things and so
I think I think I think there is a
certain why wouldn't describe human
nature as sort of completely plastic I
think there are there are a lot of
choices about who we can be like or or
what what what how it works itself out
and and you know I would you know I I
think that that's so i think i think
it's i think it's very open-ended in
that sense I'm not sure I'm answering
that as as clearly as I should I think
that I think that human nature is you
know I do think there's this dangerous
element to it and because of that you
know we obviously are in this very very
strangely this very complicated world
where there are some things that are you
know some very crazy people some very
dangerous people some very good things
happening as well and I think you know I
think that I think it is not it's not
clear how it's going to end you know if
we if we it was it was clear that it was
just all going to blow up there'd be no
point in doing anything you know and if
it was clear that everything was gonna
work out there'd be no point in doing
anything either I think I think that I
end to I tend to think that it's you
know it's
it's not like history is driven by this
automatic larger force and instead it is
going to be driven by the the choices
people make the choices of you know of
who you try to emulate and you know do
you try to you know our you know do you
try to emulate someone's doing something
heroic or we're good or something
entrepreneurial it's that's making the
world a better place for a lot of people
do you emulate a gangster or a terrorist
or someone who's doing something bad and
I think I think we want to try to shape
that in a way that's